something that we did in in 2017 I think
that was also instrumental is we did
collected bargaining reform in uh 2017
and really the only thing that our
unions the teacher unions could bargain
for was wages and it was capped at
either three percent or cost of living
rates whichever was lower and if they
they could bring additional things to
the table but both parties had to agree
on that the other thing that we did as
part of the collective bargaining reform
was paycheck protection no longer can
they deduct from their salaries they
have to actually write them a checker
they have to make the decision uh to to
support the unions and then they have to
recertify every time there's a new
contract so you know we like to say that
we took on you know the largest Monopoly
in the state with the teachers union but
it was the second one that we took on
because in 2017 it started with
um collective bargaining reform
foreign
Rubin and joining me today is the 43rd
governor of the great state of Iowa Kim
Reynolds Governor Reynolds welcome to
the Reuben report hi thanks for the
opportunity I appreciate it very much
it's great to be with you it's good to
be with you I'm glad you're here I've
seen you a couple times here in the Free
State of Florida over the last couple
months you've done some blueprint some
Florida Freedom blueprint events with
Governor DeSantis but we haven't really
got to chat too much so I thought we'd
do a little kind of get to know you and
then we'll get into the the nitty-gritty
of policy how does that sound that
sounds great that sounds great so for
the people that that don't know you at
all what should they know about Kim
Reynolds where's Kim Reynolds from
what's going on here well okay well I'm
a small town rural Iowa girl and we like
to like talk about that a lot because
you know Iowa's an agricultural State I
like to say we're actually one big small
community uh it's a population of about
3.2 million we have 99 counties
um my dad went straight into John Deere
and farmed out of high school my mom
stayed at home but let me tell you she
ran the house and threatened you know us
with everything if we didn't do what she
told us to do because Dad was coming
home at five to set us straight but
because I was I grew up in a small town
small school I participated in
everything and little did I know how
well that was going to prepare me to do
what I'm doing today so I was involved
in every sport every activity anything
that I could do
um but but again I think that helped
prepare me for a career moving forward
um what possessed the Small Town Iowa
girl to go into politics well my husband
challenged me so you know that's what
I've been in the private sector I
started working we moved uh from Mount
Pleasant to Osceola uh I started working
in the county treasurer's office and I
just I was like oh my goodness they
don't know about customer service all of
the processes were so Antiquated and um
you know I shared that with my husband
over and over and over for the next four
years lo and behold the County Treasurer
decided not to run again for re-election
which never happens and Kevin basically
my husband said to me well Kim listen
you need to run for that job and you
implement all those wonderful ideas
you've been sharing with me for the last
four years or I really don't want to
hear another thing about it and I just
didn't know anybody that had ran for
office I never really thought about it
before but I did I talked about what I
was going to do I loved I loved it the
first thing I did was tore down the wall
between the two offices I'm all about
breaking down barriers and working
together and serving uh the people that
were elected to serve and so it started
by breaking down the wall and a little
it's kind of been a theme of mine
throughout my career but I I worked
there for 19 years loved what I did I
think it's always important to bring new
leadership in and so I stepped out of a
lot of the national things that I was on
and they approached me to run for the
senate in 20 2008 not a good year for
republicans and I thought no I like what
I'm doing and I thought you know what I
can take you know what I've done in a
county I was was a large largest
geographical rule a Senate District it
was actually Seven Counties uh it was
about two hours from one into the other
and I hit the road and I started talking
to people in the district talking about
what I thought I could do for them how I
could be a voice for them lo and behold
I was one of the 18 uh in the Senate we
were in the minority that got elected
and so I've served in the local
government I've served in the state
legislature I've served in the minority
I know what that's like and what you
have to do to try to just to have your
voice be heard and to represent the
people in the minor the people that you
serve in the minority and then governor
Branstad asked me to run as lieutenant
governor and here I am
uh he got appointed to uh I'm trying to
condense it it's hard yeah yeah no this
is good this is good I feel like we're
on a game show you know the
the vast um
Kim Reynolds story uh he got up he got
appointed by President Trump to serve as
the ambassador to China and so I had the
opportunity to step into that role and I
fulfilled the last year but I
immediately had to run for um the 2018
election cycle which again was not a
great year for Republicans uh we went uh
we lost uh seats in uh in Congress and I
was running against a self-financer I am
a very hard worker uh and again I I
raised the money that I needed to raise
RGA actually helped me get across the
finish line but um I told ion was what I
was going to do and when I got elected
by two percentage points I went to work
uh I'm a little bit of a change agent uh
not just for the sake of change but for
a purpose and I'm really proud of what
we've been able to do in four years and
I think that was one of the reasons that
you know this election cycle it wasn't
just two points it was 20. so evidently
I think Iowans appreciate the direction
that we're taking the state it's been
fun it's been really fun to work on big
bold ideas and you know work with the
legislature get it done and to go back
to Iowans and said here's what I said I
would do and here's what I did and we're
just getting started so you know we're
not done yet so were you were you
exactly at 20 points do you know if you
were Governor DeSantis was uh like 20.1
or 20.2 I would assume there's some sort
of bet involved there
no we're constantly looking at what each
other's doing in each of our states and
we align fairly well on different
policies that we put in place with the
way we handled coven so he probably beat
me by just a little bit I didn't get one
of my state
um uh depart a state uh wide candidates
we flipped two 40-year incumbents two
40-year incumbents we were uh there were
only three Statewide races that flipped
Governor Lombardo was one and then we
had two in Iowa our attorney general and
our state treasurer for the first time
since the late 70s I have a republican
attorney general it makes it a lot
easier when you have a egregious
overreaching Administration
um and you're trying to protect states
rights to have an attorney general
that's willing to back you in that
process
so let's talk about some of the things
that you've done because you know people
usually focus on well now Florida and
and say Texas as like the freedom States
uh but you guys are really leading
probably more than anyone else when it
comes to education can you talk about
what's going on there with school choice
and why you decided to even get in that
fight it's not the most fun fight to be
in when you're fighting teachers unions
and everything else
well I feel I'm so passionate about it
I've been working on it for two years
and we've made progress over actually
the last four we expanded charter school
we expanded open enrollment I had school
choice language uh for the last two
years I got it through the Senate only
to have it be stopped in the house and I
made the decision this last election
cycle I was either going to be an
enabler or I was going to get involved
in some of these primaries the chair of
the education Committee in the house
blocked it for two years in a row and
I'd had it because parents were telling
me as I traveled across the state they
overwhelmingly supported parents having
the choice of where to send their child
and it shouldn't just be for those that
have the financial means to do it that
every parent should have that choice and
so I got involved in nine primaries we
were successful in eight of the nine and
the ninth one I'm proud to say supported
school choice he was a yes foe we met
right after the election and I talked to
him about why it was important and he
just really hadn't weighed in and didn't
want to take a stand on it but because
of those changes within the first two
weeks and actually it's the best Bill of
the last two years we were able to in
two weeks pass a universal school choice
I'd get there in three years boldest in
the in the country
uh and so uh and at the same time we
also uh put into account I think
providing some flexibility long overdue
flexibility for our our Public Schools
it's critical that we have a strong
public school system this is not a
zero-sum game it will Elevate all of
Education I firmly believe that but we
were able to get that across the finish
line and so and we've led a I think a
school choice Revolution across the
country Sarah Sanders blessed her heart
it's our exact language that she's
passed uh Utah is in you know Ron is
going to get it done he's going to
Universal Greg Abbott is talking about
it Governor Stitt is working on it so it
is it's incredible to actually just see
this happening and building uh across
the state I share one other thing I'm
I'm talking fast I apologize about that
but something that we did in in 2017 I
think that was also instrumental is we
did collective bargaining reform in uh
2017 and really the only thing that our
Union years the teacher unions could
bargain for was wages and it was capped
at either three percent or cost of
living wage whichever was lower and if
they they could bring additional things
to the table but both parties had to
agree on that the other thing that we
did as part of the collective bargaining
reform was a paycheck protection uh no
longer can they deduct from their
salaries they have to actually write
them a checker they have to make the
decision uh to to support the unions and
then they have to recertify every time
there's a new contract so you know we
like to say that we took on you know the
largest Monopoly in the state with the
teachers union but it was the second one
that we took on because in 2017 it
started with collective bargaining
reform just to just to give the devil
his due what's the intellectual argument
against school choice at this point I
mean we see it now happening you just
mentioned some of the states that it's
happening or it's about to happen in and
I sense that virtually all the red
states are going to go that way but
beyond just sort of like the simple
argument of the teachers unions just
want to keep their power is there is
there an intellectual argument for it at
this point do you think
no
um but what was the hardest struggle for
me and I think you're hearing this
consistently Dave honestly in a lot of
the states it's your rural school
districts you know a lot of times they
don't have the opportunities of a choice
or they feel that if it comes in it's
going to destroy them and I said that's
absolutely not the case um so the hell
this is the hysteria that the media
creates and the teachers unions I mean
Randy weingarter Garden came after me
and in in that press release that she
sent to Fox News which I don't know why
she decided that to be the outlet but
she did uh she didn't mention children
once not once but when I sat down with
rural superintendents I said look I'm
not here to change your mind I know I'm
not but I can guarantee you this is not
a zero-sum game it will Elevate all of
education but tell me what are we doing
as a state that's prohibiting you from
being Innovative and creative and and
feeling like you can compete and every
one of them pointed to chapter 12 and
what that is is just the shells of all
they need to do and you know as
Government we add add add ad and we
never take anything back and so it's
like we're so restricted we can't do
anything so I changed most of the shells
to a may we looked for redundancies we
really alleviated a lot of things that
they thought was a problem and then they
said we can't be competitive when it
comes to teachers salaries and so what
we did is we allowed some flexibility
and some unspept programs so that they
can take that money increase teacher
salaries bring on additional teachers
and be more competitive and I've
promised them we'll go back and continue
to look at some of those regulations the
regulatory environment that they're
operating in and see if we can continue
to drive Innovation give them some
flexibility much like the charter
schools that are under the public school
system but I think like everything else
they you know the hysteria when we cut
taxes we were going to destroy
government we were going to destroy
education you know the the world was
going to cease to exist that the way I
handled covid when I got the kids back
in the classroom we were going to
destroy you know kill the kids kill the
teachers so you know we've proven over
and over and over that the hysteria the
hysteria is not true and so once again
we're going to prove the media wrong and
we're going to show that our kids are
actually going to be the ones that reap
the benefit of really making sure
they're in the right environment to be
everything that they can be
how much coordination are you doing with
some of the other Governors that you
mentioned there Kevin Stitt and
obviously Governor DeSantis and maybe
Abbott some of the other guys that are
doing the similar things because it does
seem to me that most let's say
conservative leaning people are kind of
like ah the federal government it's just
broken Beyond imagination let's focus on
the states that's what Federalism is all
about but do you guys really coordinate
this stuff and say hey I'll try it here
first let's see what happens in Iowa on
school choice and then that gives you
know Sarah a little bit of room to do it
in Arkansas Etc yeah well here's the
great thing for the constituents that we
serve we are very competitive as
Governors and like the fact I had the
sixth highest income tax rate in the
country I've brought it down to the
fourth lowest when my when it finally
goes into effect
um but listen I can't stop because 15
other Governors this year have tax cuts
in their policy so uh I can tell you
what Ron talked about in his condition
of the state I can tell you what Sarah's
tax plan looks like in Arkansas I can
tell you what Doug Ducey did with
occupational licensing reform in Arizona
so there's no reason to just to recreate
the will but what I can see is what
other Governors are doing and then you
know and hopefully we're leading and
we're providing some of those examples
as well I think we have with with
education
um but but we take that and then we
adapt it to what works in our state like
I don't think you know Kevin's not able
I don't think this year to get to
Universal but he's making the steps that
we made in years prior to this so you
know he won't be done I can tell you
what his goal is I've talked to him as
we get together in RGA and have the
opportunity just to just to have
conversations and talk about what we're
doing
um it's that's where we get a lot of the
ideas and a lot of the consistency so
Sarah took our same uh school or Esa
program and hers is I almost I think
exactly the same but then she brought in
a lot of stuff I mean she hadn't done
CRT parental rights some of the other
areas that we've already Pastor that
we've passed this this session to she
put it in one big Bill but it drives all
of us to look at what we're doing and
how we can be better and more
competitive as a state because we all
want to retain the people we have we
want we Workforce is an issue so you
know whoever's winning that argument and
bringing people to our states it helps
our economy grow it helps our businesses
get the workforce that they need and
ultimately it helps our schools be more
successful as well in our community so
it's it's a win-win to have all of us
kind of looking at how we drive that
narrative
what what else should people know about
Iowa because I feel like Iowa kind of
falls under the radar and then you know
there was there was always the straw
poll the straw poll doesn't exist
anymore which I think is still shocking
to a lot of people I guess it sounds so
fun what happened why did it why did it
end they just it was too much what was
going on oh I just think everything you
have a couple of crazy things that don't
work as well and then we always are you
know people always looking for some way
to do things just a little bit
differently I'm so grateful that we were
able to hold on at least for the
Republicans the first in the nation
caucus is so short-sighted by the
Democrats to let that go to protect a
really weak president where I think it's
like only 37 percent of the democratic
party think this he should run for
re-election that drops to 23 according
to the AP poll I think for those under
45 even thinks that he should run for
reelection and they always they turn
their back on Rural America and they
wonder why they can't do well in the
heartland of America but yet they can't
take the time to come to the state and
actually talk to engaged Iowans who are
knowledgeable on the issues uh they they
do this very well they ask the important
questions it really gives the candidates
an opportunity to test their message and
you know that's valuable to see what
it's like to interact with Iowans to get
the response from people that are paying
uh attention but how do you how do you
balance that as as governor of the first
state that you know everyone's going to
I had Nikki Haley on last week she
obviously was just in Iowa obviously
Governor DeSantis was there I was Trump
there as well in the last couple weeks
yeah Trump was there as well of course
he was yeah right so how do you balance
that because obviously there's all these
strange alliances kind of forming and
I'm sure there's some stuff under the
hood and all that and it's your state
well I've made it very clear and I've
told every one of them you know as the
governor I want everybody because it is
the first in nation caucus so I want
everybody to feel welcome so I have said
to every one of them I will be happy to
be with you uh in the state of Iowa I
can help you look let you know when we
have events that I think it would be
beneficial for you to be here I'd love
to do the state fair oh by the way we'd
love to have you come to the state fair
yeah
it's awesome yeah
um so would it be happy uh to do that
but but uh it just it doesn't serve the
process well if you've got the governor
leaning in on one of the races and and
so and I and they just encourage them to
come back often and I they get it it's
been a long-standing tradition uh with
with Governors and a lot of elected
officials you have some that'll weigh in
but but for the most part honestly the
governor has stayed out because I just
as my role it's to welcome them and make
sure they feel like they have a fair
playing field but to be helpful in any
way that I can and it's it's you know
it's such an opportunity to get to
really know the candidates a lot of
times the ones that aren't successful in
getting the nomination often are brought
into the cabinet and to be able to have
those personal relationships with the
individuals that are running it's
helpful for my state as well uh let's
talk about covet a little bit because
you mentioned it briefly a few minutes
ago uh you guys basically were in that
front end of staying open and not
locking everybody down and and all of
that stuff I mean was that purely just
gut instinct by you were you just not
going to listen to All of the
bureaucratic nonsense where where did
that come from
right a lot of the infrastructure that I
needed and a pretty robust data
collection system to provide data in
this in in our state and uh
fundamentally from the beginning I mean
we we closed down for a little bit in
the beginning you know the 15 days and
we'll be through this I mean everybody
pretty much when we didn't really
understand what was going on what it
meant how it was being spread uh but as
we were able to start collecting and
data and and one of the things that from
the very beginning you know I produce
our farmers and producers produce 10 of
the nation's food supply I had to figure
out a way to keep those processing
plants up and going and the food supply
chain moving and so we needed to be able
to do the testing we need to be able to
make sure those employees knew that they
were working in a safe environment so we
could keep things going and then and
then so as we collected data but
fundamentally you know I just put my
trust in Iowa once I did a daily press
conference I was honest about the data I
told them what was going on we talked
about what you needed to do to help you
know protect against it but I put my
trust in Iowans to do the right thing
and and they did and early on it was
obvious that locking down wasn't the
wasn't the right decision it was early
on it was obvious I talked to parents I
talked to kids I talked to you know we
did Zoom calls that I needed to get the
kids back in the classroom I got sued
from some of our largest schools and to
see the statistics from the schools that
sued me the kids that dropped out and
were lost through all of that and so we
were in one of the best
fiscal shapes heading into covid we were
one of the number one States coming out
of covid and uh our economy is in a
really good place because we kept our
state for the most part open and moving
and we did it in a responsible manner
Ron and I were the first two states to
actually say my law that 100 of the the
parents had the choice to go 100 online
or 100 in the classroom but that parent
was going to make that choice on where
they wanted their child to to receive
their education nation and it's
reflected in the name scores that came
out uh we we know we didn't drop we
actually Rose we still have work to do
so you know there's learning loss I'm
not saying that but our kids are in a
better place because we had them in
school and we kept them safe what kind
of influx did you guys get of new
residents after doing some of these
things right because there has been a
freaking mess migration across the
United States as you know I'm one of
them you're one of the Florida yeah I
know so we're trying to find a better
way to track that um and our numbers
don't don't even come close to what Ron
is seeing um you know but we're probably
around 10 000 migration in but but let
me put that into context Missouri is
like excuse me Illinois has lost over
250 000 uh migration out uh Minnesota is
looking about 17 000 out so the fact
that we're positive and growing and to
your point I mean I feel like I gotta
get up and so anytime I can get to
Florida or I can get anywhere or I can
bring can candidates in where they're
talking about Iowa and what we have
going on here we just have an extremely
low cost of living a low cost of doing
business our home ownership for young
people we lead the country because it's
relatively inexpensive they can start
building that asset and equity in a home
um you know our communities are safe we
back the blue I did that in 2021 we
extensive bill that really supports our
law enforcement and and we we are
getting recognized Cato just recognized
Iowa's the most fiscally responsible
state in the in the country this year
and we now get this I don't have an
ocean or I don't have sunny weather I
got Winters but we are among the top 10
best days to live work and raise a
family Iowa made the top 10 list so I
always say you know you know we we think
this little little state in the
heartland of America people forget about
it but people are starting to recognize
uh what we have to offer here in our
state and it's been fun I think to drive
that we're not taxing our pension
retirement anymore we started that this
year I talked about reducing the tax
we're going to 3.9 Latin fair and my
goal is to get to zero but I told Ron
and Doug and and Greg I said you know
okay they can Iowans can go down there
for two damn months in the winter when
we have cold temperatures here but by
God they're going to continue to be Iowa
residents if it kills me because they're
such a valuable asset you know we want
them to stay in Iowa so that was a
really big deal for me to be able to get
that passed yeah through the legislature
I want to jump back to something you
said before so so 10 of the food supply
coming from Iowa you have to deal with
all the covid nonsense and now I sense
there's like a general feeling that all
of our supply chain things are kind of
breaking down what kind of uh issues do
you have you know even post covid making
sure that uh the farmers are going to be
able to farm and the federal
government's not going to take land and
just all the crazy things that seem to
be happening well we're watching it all
the time you know you have a lot of talk
about Chinese coming in and purchasing
Farmland well we have been we've had a
ban in place I mean we recognize our
role in feeding and fueling not only the
nation but the world and we've had a ban
in place to prevent them from buying uh
Farmland agricultural land in the state
of Iowa since 1979. I think it's one of
five states that really has some great
model language that other states are
taking a look at I think there's a total
of 15 now that have that uh in place so
you know we got to make sure that
they're not continuing to gobble up
American Farmland in 2013 mean we saw
them come in and purchase Smithville
foods which controls a lot of the U.S
pork Supply and revenue so we need to
just be conscientious of that you know
we have the supply in a surplus over
five but then you take into account that
and that the investors in all of this
are controlled by the CCP so it's
state-owned you know this is driven by
the Communist party but you've got the
war in Ukraine that's missing with the
grain uh global trade with grain you've
got inflation natural disasters and so
and supply chain issues you know you've
got an increased cost of input cost and
how that's driving the cost of food so
we need to pay more attention to food
security and what it means in this
country and we just can't be naive about
China's intentions and what they're
doing and especially when they're buying
land next to military uh installations
we've seen many attempts to do that or
to stand up a windmill in Texas that
allows them to get into the into to
their grid so you know we just need to
pay more attention Congressman feenstra
actually has dropped a bill it's called
The Farm Act you know they all have the
acronyms but to just bring more
transparency to the purchases to make
sure that the United the Secretary of AG
is on that commission and that they're
reviewing uh uh who's purchasing a lot
it's an Antiquated system and it doesn't
you know it just it does not timely and
it's very complex with the corporation
and the way that they can structure some
of those purchases so we need to take a
look at that and we need to get serious
about it uh and and put a stop to it um
you know this Farmland belongs to
American farmers and and we we can't you
know take that for granted we need to be
serious about this how worried are you
that you guys can do everything right
you know in some of these red States or
you know within reason most of the
things right and that just because of
the fiscal stuff that the government's
doing and printing money endlessly and
inflation going up and everything else
that it still is going to harm your
citizens even if you're doing right by
them well that's why I think 2024 is
critical I mean right now our physical
health is strong we have significant
surpluses we're continuing to see our
economy grow I think last year's about
11 percent growth so we'll continue to
see that but you know there it's we're
we're watching
um and it's a concern I mean it's a
constant fight against what's happening
out of Washington DC I mean the chaos
just the uncertainty the overreach is
ridiculous and uh we can you know we're
a resilient country we're resilient
people but to see what's happening at
the southern border to see you know he
continues to pay people to to not work I
mean that is it issue uh they're talking
about raising taxes they need to quit
spending money they need to unleash
American Energy I mean it's just it's
just everything is a battle and you know
I don't we can survive two more years
but by God we better get the right
person leading this country in 2024 or
or we're in trouble and just the
weakness uh on the world stage I mean
you know China's paying attention and uh
they're watching and every day you know
we see you know him fumble so many
things whether it's the Afghan
Afghanistan withdrawal or the southern
border or look what happened to Hong
Kong and then you've got you know a
statements on Taiwan and not not once
but twice but three times and then his
staff walks that back their response to
this by balloon was just embarrassing I
mean every every
person every every we're hunting we hunt
I've got the list I've got the full list
right here
on a brokering deal with Iran and Saudi
Arabia it's just like and I like
they're watching as he stumbles up the
stairs as he really you know confusion
at the podium I just I mean I take a
breath every time he goes to a Podium
because I just like they are watching
and they are patient and they are
planning and they are strategic and so
you know they're in it for the long game
so we need to you know I where they seem
to really Thrive is if we're talking
about you know woke ideology or
indoctrination and then they're all over
it you know so they have the capacity to
react it's just in a weird place you
know I mean it's unbelievable every day
what you see happening so we're going to
continue to cut taxes so they can help
our people address uh the increased
costs and inflation and do everything
that we can but it doesn't boy wouldn't
it be nice to have a partner instead of
somebody that you're working against
every single day you know it's funny I
was about to say to you that I think we
set a modern record because we went 27
minutes in an interview without saying
the word woke but you beat me to it
because my my next question did I got
two more for you but you've also you've
also LED on women's sports and making
sure that that biological girls will
compete against biological girls
something everyone knew was the right
thing say six years ago uh but did you
even want to get in this fight and and
are you getting any pushback or at this
point you feel like you've secured this
now no we've secured it and you know you
know it's just common sense but here's
the deal there's absolutely no common
sense coming out of this Administration
whatsoever the fact that I have to put
in a bill that parents are the primary
or the primary
responsible person for their kids is
just ridiculous we're putting that in
legislation uh that they are the ones
that are the in charge of their children
but you know I have three daughters I
played every sport I started with that
we get in with this so you know it's
it's a fairness issue come on I mean
female athletes just they they deserve a
Fair competition and there's a physical
advantage and everybody knows that but I
had a great we had a young woman her
name was Ashley
um erzen and she was phenomenal she ran
the 800 meter dash in high school set
the record set the record nationally was
such a tremendous advocate for this but
the same day that she broke the record
set the record for the 800 meter dash
that that same me the boys were running
also there were 85 boys that beat her
record at that same meat it's just I got
a granddaughter who runs track and the
boys and girls run at the same time all
you gotta do is look at the scoreboard
and so you know the good thing is I'm
telling you with all of the stuff that's
happening the Iowa poll has been pulling
what we've been doing as a legislature
and what I've been driving is some of my
initiatives and I'm sure they're just
crying every single day that they have
to release one of these I'm going to
have a call and send you some of them
but they buy 60 of of parents don't
think that gender identity and sexual uh
orientation should be taught to
kindergarten through sixth graders 60
and that's in Iowa and that and just
it's just on every single the issues
that we've really talked about and ran
on uh Iowans support it and they're
supporting it by pretty significant
margin and you think that you know I
thought that's what you hear when you
travel but then to have it confirmed and
you know the Iowa poll is supposed to
you know they're pretty pretty good
pretty spot on uh whether it was cutting
taxes or supporting parents or uh taking
popping candy out of snap I mean it's
they they have really uh lined up and
really validated the things that we're
working on that they support it and it's
just it's just nice I don't I don't you
know got to be careful of the polls I
mean I guess you know I love it because
it's sported what I you know what we're
doing but you know a poll is a poll and
I don't govern I don't govern by that I
mean or I wouldn't have gotten involved
in a primary but I could hear it I'm all
over this state but it it did validate
what I'm hearing from Iowans and it was
just kind of nice to see that and to
read that all right I got one more for
you I sense you probably know where I'm
going already but I've seen you at a
couple of these blueprint events with a
bunch of other Governors and Senators
you know there really does feel like
there's this massive political
realignment happening where there's
going to be a real brawl in the in the
Republican nomination process
um I don't know that uh anyone's been
floating your name for anything but it
seems like you'd be a good piece of the
puzzle uh on that side of things like do
you have any national aspirations to
that level are you just focused on Iowa
or is this just the easiest question to
give me a politician's answer
probably you won't be surprised I really
am just focused on Iowa and you know
just everything that I've done I've just
really focused on what I was doing and
just try to do the best and to really
leave it better than I found it and I've
done that just through whether it's a
private sector job or whatever level of
government that I've been involved in
and so
um like I'm coming back next year and
I'm cutting taxes we left it alone this
year because we're watching the economy
I just passed a government realignment
Bill where I go from 37 executive branch
agencies down to 16. wow I it is
incredible it will be transformational I
want to be a leader so I wanted to get
my house in order before I went into
local government and told them we can't
keep doing things and like we are uh we
can't continue continue to cut taxes and
operate in the manner that we are we
have to be more efficient and more
effective and um so and it was an
enormous bill I got it through uh both
Chambers I got it through just this week
and so it's coming to my desk and about
214 million dollar savings uh over like
three four three to four years and
that's probably conservative so so I'm
gonna keep doing what I'm doing and
we'll see what happens
I really made that one too easy all
right when's the Iowa State Fair how
about we end with that when's the Iowa
State Fair so that I can put it in the
calendar it's August is it set August
7th I think is what it is it's August
7th all right we're gonna we're gonna
see what we can do we're gonna send you
an official invitation because we want
to host uh kind of what Ron did down
with the blueprint we want to bring some
of the media in and just really have
some fun and there'll be a lot of
candidates through so I can guarantee it
will be worth your time the food is
incredible so Diet before you get here
it's just a word of advice I've seen the
pictures of the corn dogs I will not eat
for a week beforehand and I'll bring
I'll bring the whole Florida crew
I'm good with that
Governor I appreciate your time and I'll
see you in August
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell